action on abortion rights exactly two
weeks after the supreme court's
conservative majority overturned roe
versus wade the president signed an
executive order friday protecting some
abortion access for women but mr biden
said his power is limited and urged
abortion rights supporters to vote in
november this as a judge in louisiana
allowed that state's near total abortion
ban to go into effect on friday
christina rafini is at the white house
with more on the president's action
christina good morning
good morning nancy as you mentioned the
president said the best way to protect
abortion rights is to vote in lawmakers
who support them in the meantime the
white house is doing what it can
what we're witnessing wasn't a
constitutional judgment it was an
exercise in raw political power standing
in the roosevelt room a sometimes
visibly angry president biden recounted
the story of a ten-year-old girl who a
report said was denied an abortion under
her state's new laws rape six weeks
pregnant already traumatized was forced
to travel to another state
imagine being that little girl
the executive order signed yesterday
offers new guidelines for protecting
patient privacy efforts to expand access
to medical abortion and directs agencies
to take steps to ensure emergency
medical care for pregnant women and
those experiencing pregnancy loss we
cannot allow an out of control supreme
court
working in conjunction with extremist
elements of the republican party to take
away freedoms and our personal autonomy
but the power of the executive is
limited we will continue to look at all
options on the table that are legally
appropriate the order does not offer
additional privacy protections if states
pass laws requiring medical providers to
report suspected abortions would you
recommend women stop using apps that
track their health the order also tests
the ftc with clarifying the privacy
rules for using reproductive health apps
like period trackers i think people
should be really careful about that and
what kind of data can or can't be handed
over to law enforcement one of the
things that hhs did just last week was
as part of this website and also made
public practical instructions of how to
delete certain apps
that are on your phone
so that if you want to protect yourself
you have the ability to do that
now another outstanding issue is the
abortion pill the fda currently requires
pharmacies that have it to have a
special license now the white house and
the president can't direct the fda to
drop that they can't direct the fda to
do anything but they have asked the fda
to clarify the rules and regulations for
distribution nancy
christina thank you